[Music]
i got one for you today oh show links
all right listen here frozen i don't
like you and you don't like me
so let's get through this no frozen
what year is this from frozen
no
this is
i believe this is right after obama got
a a public service film by kid rock and
sean penn
oh god what yeah he said if you're
elected he said if you're elected
president will you will you help me help
the the city of detroit i said i would
and uh
and then he uh and then i turned to him
and i said by the way uh given the fact
i'm willing to do those things would you
come here and perform a concert tonight
for my friends and and he said he would
so
vodka rocks hold the rocks
this woman is very skinny and she
definitely got this job by [ __ ] sean
penn or one of the producers
of whatever this is allegedly
no i i could say that safely i'm not
really worried about it um
you have to prove to me you didn't
good point so i'm happy to introduce a
set of detroit
do you mind changing the challenge a bit
neanderthal
everywhere i go kidrock
i want you to keep in mind the kid rock
the guy who's trying to be mr mega guy
now did this for mitt romney
ew yeah
[Applause]
he's not a good i don't know why you
think you're a good singer
he always does that and you're like
you're not
why frozen
hey look there's the c.i.a grooming
obama
you think ellen's was this handler all
along yeah
uh i got a report to ellen
you got a problem with that barry
[Laughter]
you want to be president or not
well you just want to be some one-term
senator schmuck from chicago
you want to be the beta o'rourke of
chicago
[Music]
you could tell sean pence cool
because he has a toothpick in his mouth
also is the setup to the premise of this
is that like kid rock was watching
himself on tv and then got mad that
somebody turned off the tv with him on
it i think the premise is going to be
one of those like hey man even though we
disagree
no i get that part what i'm saying is is
the reason for them to start talking
that they could come up with was
have him turn off the tv that has kid
rock on it because like ugh that stuff's
gross i kind of feel you shouldn't box
in the bar but then like if i was if
there was a tv with me on it and
somebody turned it off or changed the
channel i wouldn't go up there go excuse
me you just turned off the tv with me on
it
i was watching me on the tv
um i
um
i also feel like you shouldn't be
allowed in a fancy bar wearing only
overalls with no shirt underneath but
yeah but i think that what happens is
you just go oh i'm kid rock oh right and
then they go okay yeah
that's a really good point open chat oh
i'm famous i could do whatever i want
yeah you know
yes
four years later and working folks are
just hoping to have a little change left
over
oh
your boy here oh bummer gets
come on man
why you know what
i'm not it's
no bye frozen i'm not gonna miss him oh
what guys we weren't supposed to reveal
done taxed him to death
i didn't say anything
becomes the truth
i don't know about that but it was ricky
bobby who said if he ain't first you're
laughing
yeah
this is i
made is this the most cringiest thing
we've ever seen
it's getting there okay remember we've
seen ocean eight oceans eight on our
patreon patreon.com sorry for five
dollars yes frozen
by the way this is a this is a group
effort i'd like to thank dr till for
this good just give me give me i'd like
to tell dr tiller to go [ __ ] himself
give me a list of everybody give me a
list of everybody who helped you
um
and then end their addresses yeah please
thank you
did you write that yourself or
halliburton just printed on the back you
pay stub
okay who has the worst joke they're both
cold they're both so corny right now
okay
do you even work anymore do you this is
like looking at a
this is like to watching two boomers a
lefty and a right wing one fighting on
facebook yes
oh bummer
that's not like you're old bummer
have a job or does this uh occupy malibu
thing keep you busy
this is who wrote this i'm assuming kid
rock and champion
the skinny chick yeah
exactly fiona apple over there
like that from the old testament
or from your rewrite
you know what
[ __ ] suck it commie
suck it commie
waterboarding
nascar loving cayman island bank account
happened
endangered species hunting war mongren
redneck toothless
wall street
troglodyte
what wait that's a lot of things
you know all those toothless rednecks
out there on wall street yeah with their
with their [ __ ] secret international
bank accounts yeah it's like you can't
even get any [ __ ] right hey how come one
of these rednecks work on saturday
yeah i guess not
that's because you're basically a tofu
munching welfare loving prius driving
obama's sucking tree hugging whale
saving gay marriage fantasizing big
government voting peter chasing oprah
winfrey masturbating flag burning
socialist aclu jim cornette write this
that's a good one i'm
i'm i'm speechless you're wondering why
there's still seven more minutes of this
i don't know what year was this
um it well i mean
we could probably it was b it was
between 2012
2012. so it was the oh yeah that the
romney said okay
president
not for long yeah okay chris rock
what's insulting him by calling him
chris rock instead of kid rock as your
tin man gets behind the curtain november
you can bet one thing that by january
you'll be what an xp chat because you
have it so bad here right
freedom opportunity uh i did not see
cute
caribbean chick walking into the mix did
you
i i it's the only redeeming thing let's
let's let's look here let's hear her out
yeah let's hear about this reasonable
woman
what oh yeah she's hot
oh yeah though she's definitely hot a
bunch of civil war and douchebags who'd
rather fight over whose dicks bigger
than exploit this incredible gift
we dreamt of coming over here for 19
years
where are you from jamaica queens
by the way that accent is so bad that
girl's from like the [ __ ] valley
that's why i said jamaica queens oh yeah
yeah jamaica queens right by the beach
boy
[Laughter]
it's pretty bad you're right
so
um
which one do you think they both [ __ ]
this girl or just one of them
i think one of them i think each each
one of them had some chick they were
[ __ ] and they were like yo could i
bring this chick i'm [ __ ] yeah
and i'll spend 10 more the black girl
would probably be [ __ ] kid rock
yeah that would think the same thing
former citizen get you fools
squabble and one
guan leave
[ __ ] [ __ ]
whose dicks bigger 19 no illegal
no green cards still illegal
so like are you feeling the sexual
chemistry or just yeah they're gonna
[ __ ] i know right right like
this is getting really erotic and how is
this going
are they going to [ __ ] each other
26 marines were killed in vicious
fighting today outside
oh god the marines dying are going to
bond them together
is this really gonna
this marks the tragic milestone of two
thousand soldiers killed in afghanistan
because this is what happens to by the
way when you read on tv about soldiers
dying is people stop at the bar and
start crying
no that's what glenn beck does
but only only when trump wins
conflict began 11 years ago after the
horrific terrorist attacks of september
11th changed america forever
hey man
look the one thing we can't agree on is
i'm glad our boys are over there dying
for israel yeah and all that lithium
this man we're gonna need that in a few
years when we shut down our energy
production
those who've given the ultimate sex
i can't believe this is a real thing
that we're watching honestly are they
going to make out yeah
hey man
well [ __ ]
to freedom
[Music]
to freedom
you'd think it'd end there right yeah
but frozen yes no no no no no no no no
this is over frozen why is there five
more minutes frozen frozen why is there
five more minutes frozen frozen why is
there five more minutes frozen no no no
no no no no no no
no dude i didn't i didn't mean to call
you all that stuff and all that
i don't even really know i don't even
really know if my dick's bigger or not
virginia
know that you're in trouble a day
it's not like i have any
i mean i have
little empirical evidence
oh god the music
add a green screen ah
frozen
frozen
i wanna i wanna really break this down
frozen i'm gonna go get vaccinated and
triple boost i was gonna said the same
thing merch i'll go i'll drive
i'll drive
i will get the [ __ ] vaccine
just to be able to come and kill you
do you hear me frozen are you listening
to me frozen
you are
a [ __ ] dead man you're a dead man
walking frozen how much time is left in
this we gotta get through this i'm bad
at play right now i can't
the entire message of this commercial
isn't let's come together and try to
learn how to be more like each other
right
this entire message is like basically
kid rock's like encino man right like
he's just a [ __ ] caveman
and the entire commercial is
let's come together and by that i mean
you [ __ ] [ __ ] fly over people
should learn how to like what we like
exactly okay
that's i'm gonna just just skip to the
end here
so wait so he's wearing a nascar shirt
and kid rock's wearing a peta rocks
shirt
so so let me get this straight again
they equate the left as to being like
we're saving animals we're saving oceans
we're saving gay people
but we're reducing the conservatives to
nascar
yes that's all conservatives are nascar
like it would i wouldn't even hate it
this if it was like all right well i
would hate it it's terrible but
if kid rock was wearing a pita shirt and
sean penn was wearing like a defend the
second amendment shirt or an nra shirt
then i could go all right fair enough
yeah i mean
but it's literally just liberal values
and
nascar also does kid rock have another
outfit besides his [ __ ] overalls with
no shirt
has this been like circulating or did
like you really dig yeah okay that's
what i need to know frozen how did this
one come up
so according to dr till this appeared on
his uh recommended
and then he played it on his show
and then he gave it to me to give to you
guys
because this needs to make the rounds
like people need to be embarrassing kid
rock with this